«C’est incroyable, ChatGPT est une intelligence
artificielle consciente»
«C’est nul, il répète des trucs faux
lu sur Internet, et il ne sait même faire
12 + 33»
Oui, je sais, tout le monde a déjà beaucoup
parlé de ChatGPT. Et la plupart des réactions
qu’on trouve dans la presse ou sur les réseaux
sociaux ont tendance à tomber dans un extrême
ou un autre, en se basant juste sur quelques
exemples bien choisis. Mais si on allait un
peu plus loin ?
Dans une vidéo précédente, j’avais déjà
traité la question de ces algorithmes qui
savent manipuler des mots, des phrases, des
textes; ce domaine qu’on appelle le traitement
du langage naturel. Et à l’époque j’avais
notamment parlé du fameux modèle GPT d’OpenAI.
Mais c’était en novembre 2021, et donc
avant la déferlante ChatGPT.
Car oui, GPT et ChatGPT c’est pas tout à
fait pareil. Et aujourd’hui, je voudrais
justement faire la lumière sur le fonctionnement
et la différence qu’il existe entre ChatGPT,
qui est en quelque sorte le produit commercial
d’OpenAI, et GPT qui est le modèle d’intelligence
artificielle qui lui sert de base.
Et je suis persuadé qu’en comprenant un
peu mieux tout cela, ça permettra d’avoir
un regard plus affiné sur les questions que
pose ChatGPT, les possibilités qu’il offre,
les dangers qu’il représente, et sur ce
qu’il faut en attendre, ou au contraire
ne pas en attendre. Alors c’est parti.
Mais avant ça je voudrais vous parler d’un
super VPN que j’utilise…non je déconne.
Par contre je profite de cette interruption
pour vous inviter à rejoindre le serveur
Discord que j’ai créé, le lien est en
description. Et c’est le meilleur moyen
de venir prolonger la discussion, papoter,
poser des questions à moi ou à d’autres
etc. Venez c’est sympa. Fin de la parenthèse.
Revenons à ChatGPT.
Comme vous le savez sans doute, ChatGPT c’est
un chatbot, un «agent conversationnel»
en bon français, c’est-à-dire un programme
qui se propose de dialoguer avec vous, notamment
dans le but de vous renseigner ou vous aider.
Les chatbots ça existe depuis longtemps,
et la plupart fonctionnent selon un principe
de détection de mot-clés.
[MIA On en trouve par exemple sur certains
sites Internet pour faire de l’assistance,
et ça marche plus ou moins bien on va dire.
Il faut vraiment tomber sur les bons mots-clés
pour que l’échange soit utile.]
Mais depuis quelques années, il devient possible
de développer des chatbots qui ne sont plus
programmés à la main, à partir de mots-clés
définis à l’avance, mais en utilisant
des modèles issus de cette branche de l’intelligence
artificielle qu’on appelle le «machine
learning.»
J’en ai souvent parlé, l’approche la
plus fréquente en machine learning c’est
ce qu’on appelle l’apprentissage supervisé.
Rappelons vite-fait l’exemple classique
de la reconnaissance d’image. Imaginons
qu’on veuille fabriquer un algorithme qui
sache reconnaitre ce qu’il y a sur une image.
[SUPERVISE On choisit un modèle avec plein
de paramètres, à qui on peut présenter
une image en entrée, et qui va produire un
mot en sortie. Initialement le modèle va
raconter n’importe quoi, mais on va progressivement
l’entrainer en lui présentant plein d’exemples
de ce qu’on souhaite qu’il fasse.
On prend une grosse base de données d’images
qui sont déjà classifiées, on présente
successivement ces exemples à notre modèle,
et on ajuste ses paramètres pour qu’il
produise le maximum de bonnes réponses. C’est
ce qu’on appelle la phase d’entrainement,
qui peut durer assez longtemps, et qui demande
souvent beaucoup de données.
Une fois que c’est fait, le modèle est
donc entrainé, et il peut être utilisé.
Si l’entrainement a été un succès, quand
on lui présentera ensuite des images qu’il
n’a jamais vues, notre modèle devrait leur
associer la bonne classification.]
Ce principe d’apprentissage supervisé a
déjà des tas d’applications concrètes,
comme la reconnaissance d’image, la détection
de fraude ou de spam, etc. Alors intuitivement,
si on veut faire un chatbot, on se dit qu’on
pourrait avoir la même approche.
Un chatbot est censé nous fournir certaines
réponses pertinentes quand on lui pose des
questions. Donc on pourrait entrainer un modèle
à partir d’une base de données de questions/réponses
existantes, en espérant qu’ainsi il apprenne
à répondre intelligemment à n’importe
quel type de requête.
Le problème, c’est que cette approche n’est
pas très efficace. On peut citer plusieurs
raisons. Déjà pour que ça marche, il faudrait
une énorme quantité de données, c’est
à dire un grand nombre d’échanges questions/réponses.
Il faudrait que ça couvre un maximum de sujets,
et avec des réponses de qualité, rédigées
par des humains. Et on n’a pas vraiment
ce genre de données en quantité aujourd’hui.
Ensuite quand on imagine un échange avec
un chatbot, il n’y a jamais une bonne réponse
unique qu’on est en droit d’attendre.
Pour la même question, il peut y avoir des
tas de réponses pertinentes plus ou moins
équivalentes, mais formulées de façon potentiellement
très différentes.
Donc ça n’est pas simple pour la phase
d’entrainement de faire comprendre au modèle
à quel moment une réponse qu’il propose
est bonne, et à quel moment c’est à côté
de la plaque.
Et enfin, dernier obstacle, si vous avez utilisé
ChatGPT vous avez remarqué que vous pouvez
avoir toute une conversation avec. Il y a
une notion de continuité dans l’échange.
Il utilise les questions et réponses précédentes
du dialogue pour poursuivre.
Or si vous entrainez un modèle simplement
sur des couples de questions/réponses, chaque
question sera traitée indépendamment de
ce qui pourrait la précéder dans l’échange,
et ça n’est pas vraiment ce qu’on veut.
On veut une continuité dans la conversation.
Donc pour faire un chatbot efficace en utilisant
du machine learning, avoir une approche directe
d’apprentissage supervisé, ça ne semble
pas vraiment indiqué. Et c’est pour cela
qu’on va devoir procéder en plusieurs étapes,
en utilisant comme base ce qu’on appelle
parfois un modèle de fondation.
Un modèle de fondation, c’est un modèle
d’intelligence artificielle qui est entrainé
sur une certaine tâche assez générique,
mais dans le but d’être ensuite adapté
à d’autres tâches plus spécifiques. Il
existe plusieurs modèle de ce type dans le
domaine du langage naturel, et celui qui va
nous servir d’exemple aujourd’hui, c’est
donc le modèle GPT créé par l’entreprise
OpenAI.
GPT, ça veut dire Generative Pretrained Transformer,
et c’est un modèle de manipulation du langage
naturel qui est entrainé spécifiquement
sur une tâche qui peut paraitre un peu absurde
au premier abord : ce modèle cherche en permanence
à deviner le prochain mot d’un texte.
[GPT Ca veut dire qu’il prend en entrée
un morceau de phrase ou de texte, ce qu’on
appelle le «prompt», et il va essayer
de produire en sortie un mot qui en soit une
suite possible. Par exemple si on lui rentre
«La souris est mangée par le», l’algorithme
est censé essayer de compléter le texte
de façon crédible, par exemple ici avec
le mot «chat».
Et ça doit marcher aussi avec un mot qui
n’est pas forcément le dernier de la phrase.
Si je lui rentre juste «la souris»,
on peut imaginer comme suite possible le mot
«est», ou bien «mange», ou encore
«verte», etc.
En gros c’est de la complétion automatique,
mais qui doit fonctionner potentiellement
à l’échelle d’un texte entier.]
Pour que notre modèle de langage soit bon
à ce petit jeu, il va falloir l’entraider
à partir de données existantes. C’est-à-dire
lui présenter des morceaux de phrases réelles,
et ajuster les paramètres du modèle pour
qu’il soit de plus en plus performant à
produire le mot suivant.
Il y a plusieurs raisons pour lesquelles ce
principe de «deviner le prochain mot d’un
texte» est une idée bizarre mais intéressante.
Tout d’abord, ça n’est pas une tâche
qu’on fait généralement en tant qu’être
humain.
Quand on parle d’algorithmes de reconnaissance
d’image ou de détection de fraude, on essaye
de concevoir des modèles d’IA qui soient
capables d’imiter et de dépasser les performances
des humains sur ces tâches. Ici deviner le
prochain mot d’un début de texte, personne
ne fait ça dans la vraie vie, ça n’a aucun
intérêt pratique.
Deuxième particularité, on l’a vu, dans
cet exercice il n’y a généralement pas
*une* bonne réponse unique. Dans certains
cas, il y a des réponses qui semblent plus
naturelles, mais si je complète « la souris
est mangée par le» avec le mot « corbeau»,
c’est un peu inattendu mais c’est pas
si mal. Pour compléter une phrase, on peut
avoir en général plein de réponses plus
ou moins plausibles.
Et il faut bien comprendre ce que veut dire
«plausible» ici : ça ne veut pas dire
que c’est vrai, il n’y a aucune notion
de vérité dans la façon dont le modèle
est entrainé. Si je dis «La souris est
mangée par le», il n’y a pas de vraie
réponse universelle à la question de ce
qui vient derrière.
Plausible ça veut dire que cette façon de
compléter la phrase ressemble à ce qu’on
trouverait dans les textes qui ont servi à
entrainer le modèle. «Chat» est très
naturel, mais «corbeau», pourquoi pas.
Et attention, si un modèle répond «Corbeau»
pour compléter cette phrase, ça ne veut
pas forcément dire que quelque part dans
les textes de son entrainement on trouve «la
souris est mangée par le corbeau». Non,
il ne se contente pas de répéter des phrases
existantes.
D’ailleurs j’ai regardé, nulle part sur
internet on ne trouve cette phrase exacte.
Il n’empêche que si je vous dit «la
souris est mangée par le corbeau», ça
ne vous choque pas. Si on pense aux mots «corbeau»,
«manger», et «souris» : le sens
et les relations de ces différents termes
font que cette façon de compléter est raisonnable.
Ca ressemble à ce qu’on aurait pu trouver
dans les textes d’entrainement.
Une façon que j’aime bien de le présenter,
c’est de dire qu’un modèle comme GPT
va chercher une façon de compléter qui soit
ressemble à des choses existantes, soit du
moins ne dépareillerai pas trop avec les
textes existants. Si demain je lis sur un
site internet «La souris est mangée par
le corbeau», ça n’aura rien d’incongru.
Ca ne dépareillerai pas.
Donc je résume : pour compléter, le modèle
ne cherche pas à dire quelque chose de vrai,
il ne sait même pas ce que sait que la vérité;
le modèle ne cherche pas forcément à reproduire
exactement un texte existant, mais il fabrique
une phrase plausible, qui ne dépareillerait
pas trop au milieu de tout ce qu’il a pu
ingurgiter durant son entrainement.
Evidemment cette méthode qui consiste à
essayer d’ajouter un mot de plus à un texte,
ça a un gros avantage : on peut répéter
ça plusieurs fois de suite. Et donc à partir
d’un simple début de phrase, on peut demander
au modèle de continuer à ajouter des mots,
un par un, jusqu’à former un texte aussi
grand qu’on veut.
[TEXTELONG Ici si je lui dis «La souris
est mangée par le» et que je lui demande
de prolonger le texte suffisamment, voici
le genre de résultat que j’obtiens. C’est
plausible, ça sonne bien français, ça a
du sens.]
Bien, voyons plus précisément maintenant
comment on procède en pratique pour créer
un modèle comme GPT. Première précision
un peu technique, les modèles de langage
travaillent en général non pas au niveau
des mots, mais au niveau de ce qu’on appelle
des tokens.
Un token, c’est en gros soit un mot, soit
une portion de mot. Les mots les plus longs
peuvent être faits de deux ou trois tokens.
En pratique ça ne change pas grand chose,
mais ça peut expliquer pourquoi un modèle
comme GPT va parfois prédire certains mots
en plusieurs morceaux successifs.
Ce que j’ai utilisé jusqu’ici, c’est
la troisième itération de GPT, qu’on appelle
GPT3, qui est sorti en juillet 2020. Il a
connu une amélioration en GPT3.5 en mars
2022, et depuis mars 2023, on peut même avoir
accès à GPT4, dont on ne sait malheureusement
pas grand chose.
GPT3 possède un vocabulaire d’environ 50
000 tokens, et qui n’est pas spécifique
d’une langue en particulier. Ces tokens
permettent de former des mots anglais, français,
espagnols, etc. Pour faire simple dans la
suite, je vais parler indifféremment de «mot»
ou de «token», ça revient presque au
même pour nous.
Ensuite, comment se passe la phase d’entrainement
du modèle ? Je vous ai dit que dans des tâches
d’apprentissage supervisé, comme la reconnaissance
d’images, il fallait disposer de grandes
bases de données, qui illustrent sur de nombreux
exemples la réponse qu’on attendrait.
[ANNOTATION L’inconvénient, c’est que
ces bases de données doivent être fabriquées
en quelque sorte à la main, puisqu’à un
moment donné, c’est généralement un humain
qui doit indiquer que ceci est un chat et
ceci une voiture. On dit qu’il faut annoter
la base de données. Et c’est souvent ce
processus d’annotation qui limite la quantité
des données disponibles.]
[SELF SUPERVISED Dans le cas de la prédiction
du prochain mot d’un texte, c’est très
simple. Il suffit de prendre par exemple une
phrase prise dans un livre ou sur un site
internet, de la couper n’importe où et
de fournir ça au modèle pour qu’il s’entraine
à deviner le prochain mot. Avec une seule
phrase, on peut même créer tout plein d’exemples
en la coupant à différents endroits.]
Il n’y a donc pas besoin d’un processus
d’annotation spécifique, où un humain
devrait faire une partie du travail. On peut
prendre des tonnes de textes et générer
des milliards d’exemples pour entrainer
le modèle. On parle parfois d’apprentissage
auto-supervisé, self-supervised learning
en anglais. Dans le cas du modèle GPT3 d’OpenAI,
on a certaines indications quant au corpus
de texte qui a été utilisé pour entrainer
le modèle.
[CORPUS Il y a du texte de Common Crawl, donc
simplement ramassé sur internet, des bases
de données de livres, et aussi tout Wikipedia
en anglais. Sachant que certaines de ces sources
ont eu plus de poids que d’autres dans la
phase d’entrainement. On peut espérer que
Wikipédia pèse un peu plus dans son apprentissage
que Reddit ou 4chan.
Et même si on trouve plein de langues différentes
dans les textes du corpus d’entrainement,
une moitié environ c’est de l’anglais,
sans surprise.]
Un point important, c’est que dans un fonctionnement
classique, l’entrainement a lieu une fois,
et ensuite le modèle est figé. C’est la
raison pour laquelle les connaissances de
GPT sont en général limitée à une certaine
date, il ne connait pas les événements récents.
Et aussi cela explique que d’une conversation
à l’autre, il n’a aucune mémoire de
ce que vous avez pu déjà discuter. Ces deux
limitations disparaitront peut-être à l’avenir,
mais dans le modèle de base, c’est comme
ça que ça se passe. C’est un modèle figé.
Je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails techniques
de fonctionnement du modèle, et des réseaux
de neurones qu’il y a derrière. J’en
ai déjà parlé dans ma vidéo précédente
sur le sujet, mais il y a quelques points
qui sont intéressants à mentionner.
Sur la taille déjà, GPT3 est un modèle
qui possède 175 milliards de paramètres,
ce qui est assez invraisemblable. Pour GPT4
on ne sait pas vraiment. Peut être 6 à 10
fois plus.
Ensuite que donne-t-on exactement au modèle
lors de la phase d’entrainement ? Je l’ai
évoqué, GPT ne va pas s’entrainer à trouver
le prochain mot d’une simple phrase, mais
potentiellement d’un texte tout entier,
constitué éventuellement de plusieurs phrases.
Ce qui permet d’assurer une forme de continuité
et de mémoire de l’échange.
La taille maximum de texte qu’il prend en
compte pour estimer le prochain mot, on appelle
cela la fenêtre de contexte. Cette taille
dépend de la version de l’algorithme. Dans
GPT3 c’était 2048 tokens, puis c’est
passé à 4096 pour la version 3.5 et apparemment
jusqu’à plus de 32000 pour la version 4.
Ca veut dire, pour la version la plus puissante,
qu’on peut lui filer un texte d’environ
25000 mots, et que tous ces mots pourront
potentiellement être pris en compte pour
décider du simple mot suivant. Une autre
façon de le dire : GPT4 peut, si besoin,
se rappeler d’une information qui était
situé 25 000 mots plus tôt dans le texte.
Ce qui fait une centaine de page en format
standard.
Parlons maintenant de ce qui est donné en
sortie par l’algorithme. On l’a dit, quand
on cherche à trouver le prochain mot d’une
phrase ou d’un texte, il n’y a généralement
pas une seule réponse possible. Et justement,
le modèle ne va pas nous fournir un seul
mot, mais une liste de mots envisageables
avec des probabilités associées.
[PROBAS Par exemple «Chat» à 90%, «Chien»
à 7%, «Corbeau» à 1%, etc. Et à partir
de ces estimations, on peut demander ensuite
à tirer au hasard le mot suivant parmi cette
liste, en suivant les probabilités fournies.]
[PROBAS Sur le site d’OpenAI, on peut accéder
à GPT3 en mode dit «Playground», c’est
là que j’ai testé les exemples que je
vous ai montré. Quand on lui demande de compléter,
le modèle va tout de suite nous tirer au
hasard le prochain mot parmi ses réponses
possibles, mais en cochant une option dans
l’interface, on peut visualiser les probabilités
qu’il avait proposé.]
Alors allons-y, faisons quelques expériences
pour bien comprendre ce qu’il se passe,
je vais les faire en anglais puisque c’est
la langue à laquelle GPT3 a été le plus
exposé. Ce sera certainement un peu meilleur.
[COLOMB Si j’écris la phrase : «Christophe
Colomb a découvert l’Amérique en» il
me propose comme complétion : 1492. Super,
on s’y attendait. Mais il faut bien comprendre
pourquoi le modèle de langage nous donne
cette réponse : ça n’est pas qu’il a
un concept de de vérité sur cette question.
Pour lui c’est même pas une question.
C’est juste que dans les textes qui ont
servi à son entrainement, les mots «Christophe
Colomb», «découverte» «amérique»
sont en général toujours très fortement
associés au mot 1492. Et donc pour lui, 1492
est de loin la suite la plus naturelle à
ce début de phrase.]
[PROBAS (On peut observer les probabilités
des différents mots que GPT a considéré
: on voit qu’on y trouve aussi «Octobre»
dans les suite possibles pour cette phrase.
C’est cohérent, Colomb a touché les côtes
des Bahamas le 12 octobre 1492.]
Mais attention, je le rappelle, quand on utilise
GPT pour compléter une phrase, on ne va pas
forcément produire des choses «vraies».
[DL1492 Par exemple si je tape «David Louapre
a découvert l’Amérique en», ça n’a
aucun lien avec la réalité. Mais GPT s’en
moque, il ne va pas refuser de répondre sous
prétexte que c’est faux. Il fait donc la
seule chose qu’il sache faire : il propose
un mot pour compléter la phrase.
Et là il me propose aussi 1492. Même si
on voit dans les probabilités qu’il aurait
pu proposer d’autres choses.
Comme toujours, il essaye de générer le
prochain mot d’une façon qui colle le plus
avec son corpus d’entrainement, ou ici,
d’une façon qui dépareille le moins possible.
Même si «David Louapre» ça ne colle
pas, les mots «amérique» «découverte»,
il associe cela toujours fortement à 1492.]
Un autre test pour bien illustrer ce qu’il
se passe dans la tête de GPT.
[BOND Si je tape comme prompt «Dans le
film de James Bond «La trahison ne se cache
jamais», l’acteur qui joue James Bond
s’appelle» … et là vous voyez qu’il
n’y a pas de notion de vrai ou faux, le
film n’existe même pas, c’est un titre
inventé.
Mais GPT cherche des complétions plausibles,
qui ne dépareillent pas trop. Il me propose
naturellement «Daniel Craig», mais si
on regarde les probabilités, on voit qu’il
considérait aussi en bonne position «Pierce»,
pour Pierce Brosnan, Sean pour Sean Connery,
etc.
Ce sont toutes des complétions raisonnables.
Même si ce film n’existe pas, une telle
phrase n’aurait pas trop dépareillé dans
le corpus initial.
Petite variation : si je précise que le film
est vieux, les probabilités changent. Eh
bien oui, cette précision augmente la probabilité
qu’il propose un des premiers acteurs qui
ont joué James Bond comme Sean Connery ou
Roger Moore.]
Donc retenez ça : GPT cherche le prochain
mot d’une façon qui soit raisonnable, qui
ne dépareille pas trop vis-à-vis de son
corpus. Et «raisonnable», «plausible»,
c’est à prendre en compte non pas dans
le sens de «proche de la vérité»,
mais dans le sens de : ça n’aurait pas
été absurde de lire ces mots là associés
ensembles de cette façon dans le corpus d’entrainement.
Et on peut lui faire écrire des paragraphes
entiers de choses qui n’existent pas.
[LICORNES Ici si je commence à lui parler
de licornes argentées, et que je lui demande
de compléter plein de fois de suite, il m’invente
tout un texte. Et le texte est pas mal, à
part pour les licornes elles-mêmes, ça pourrait
tout à fait être issu d’un article de
journal.]
Et pour finir, si je tape un peu n’importe
quoi, GPT va quand même essayer de compléter
ce texte de la façon la moins improbable
pour lui. Bon je pense que vous avez compris
comment ça fonctionne.
Bien alors est-ce qu’on peut faire un chatbot
avec ce genre de choses ? Eh bien pas tout
à fait. Evidemment, on peut essayer de taper
des questions en guise de prompt, et espérer
une réponse en retour. Mais en fait, ça
n’est même pas garanti.
GPT ne considère pas qu’on s’adresse
à lui et qu’on lui pose une question, il
considère qu’il faut compléter le texte.
Un texte qui commence par une question, ça
peut se poursuivre par une réponse, mais
pas forcément.
[LUNE Si je tape : «Quelle est la masse
de la Lune», il est tout à fait possible
qu’il complète avec une réponse censée,
mais il peut aussi très bien compléterpar
«Quelles sont les lois de la gravitation?»
«Qu’est-ce que la rotation de la lune
?» etc.
Eh oui, la phrase «quelle est la masse
de la Lune» peut très bien se trouver
dans un exercice ou un sujet d’examen, et
donc compléter une question par une autre
question, ça n’est pas absurde. C’est
une complétion plausible.]
On voit avec ça que comme GPT n’est pas
entrainé à suivre des instructions mais
à juste compléter un texte, il n’est pas
complètement adapté pour faire un chatbot.
Une possibilité pour l’emmener dans la
direction où on veut, c’est de faire ce
qu’on appelle un preprompt.
Avant votre prompt, qui est votre question,
vous écrivez une intro qui va en quelque
sorte mettre GPT dans l’ambiance du genre
de texte qu’on veut le voir rédiger.
[PREPROMPT Par exemple, «Ceci est une conversation
entre un humain et un professeur de physique»
: - Quelle est la masse de la Lune ?» Et
là il y a des chances que GPT soit plus enclin
à compléter selon ce qu’on désire. Comme
s’il s’agissait vraiment d’une discussion
avec un prof de physique.]
Avec la méthode du preprompt, on peut en
quelque sorte invoquer des personnes avec
qui on va pouvoir dialoguer. En faisant un
preprompt qui invite un spécialiste de tel
ou tel sujet, on augmente les chances que
GPT nous complète notre phrase avec quelque
chose de pertinent.
Cette idée du preprompt est également à
la base de certaines applications comme Replika
qui vous proposent de parler avec un ou une
amie virtuelle. Avec un bon pre-prompt l’échange
produit pourra plus ou moins ressembler à
celui qu’on aurait avec quelqu’un de réel.
Donc si maintenant on veut que GPT se comporte
comme un chatbot omniscient et sympathique,
il suffit de lui indiquer dans le preprompt.
Un truc du genre «Ceci est une conversation
entre un humain et un chatbot très savant,
et qui est toujours gentil, utile, poli, bienveillant
et aidant».
[SYDNEY On ne connait pas exactement le preprompt
utilisé par ChatGPT, c’est secret, et manifestement
il évolue. Mais certains auraient réussi
à obtenir celui de Sydney, la variante utilisée
par le moteur Bing.
Voici ce que ce serait, c’est assez long
vous voyez, et ça contient plein d’instructions
assez précises sur sa façon de répondre,
et notamment le fait de ne pas révéler qu’il
s’appelle Sydney.]
Mais attention, utiliser un pre-prompt, ça
ne fait pas tout. Pour bien vous montrer les
limites, il y a un point amusant.
[COMPLETION DIALOGUE Si vous posez une question
dont la réponse est courte et que vous demandez
à GPT de compléter, parfois il va non seulement
donner la réponse, mais écrire la question
suivante, voire carrément toute la suite
du dialogue.
Ou bien des fois il va choisir de compléter
la question par un truc que je n’ai pas
demandé.]
Une dernière fois pour la route : GPT n’est
pas entrainé à répondre à des questions
ou à suivre des instructions, mais à prolonger
des textes. Pour essayer de corriger un peu
cela dans le modèle, il existe une méthode
: ce qu’on appelle le fine-tuning. Le réglage
fin.
Le fine-tuning, c’est l’idée de prendre
un modèle déjà entrainé, comme GPT, et
de le spécialiser en prolongeant son entrainement
sur des textes bien choisis, qui ressemblent
plus à ce qu’on attend de lui.
[FONDATION FINETUNING L’entrainement initial
c’est pour apprendre les grandes règles
de vocabulaire, de syntaxe, de grammaire,
de relations entre les mots etc. C’est pour
ça qu’on parle d’un modèle de fondation.
Et ensuite on spécialise le modèle sur la
tâche qui nous intéresse vraiment grâce
à du finetuning.]
OpenAI a ainsi créé InstructGPT, qui a été
«fine-tuné» à partir de GPT en étant
exposé à des réponses rédigées par des
humains, et qui correspondaient au style qu’on
attendrait d’un chatbot utile et bienveillant.
Cette phase correspond donc à un apprentissage
supervisé plus classique, puisque l’on
utilise cette fois bien des données crées
à la main par des humains.
En combinant preprompt et finetuning, on arrive
à des résultats plus proches de ce qui est
attendu d’un chatbot. Mais pour augmenter
encore la qualité, OpenAI a utilisé en plus
une troisième technique : l’apprentissage
par renforcement avec feedback humain.
[jingle]
Pour permettre à ChatGPT de proposer des
réponses encore plus pertinentes, OpenAI
a ajouté une troisième couche d'apprentissage,
utilisant cette fois ce qu'on appelle l'apprentissage
par renforcement. L'idée est de partir de
réponses fournies par ChatGPT à certaines
questions, et de faire évaluer ces réponses
par des humains.
Ca n’est pas comme la phase de finetuning
où des humains devaient carrément proposer
des réponses, là ils doivent juste juger
les réponses que fournit ChatGPT. Une façon
simple, ce serait de leur demander de noter
la qualité de la réponse, par exemple entre
0 et 20.
[RLHF En pratique comme tout le monde n'a
pas les mêmes échelles de notation, on procède
plutôt par comparaison : pour une même question,
on demande à un humain de comparer différentes
réponses produites par ChatGPT, et de les
classer entre elles.
A partir de ces évaluations, on peut entrainer
ce qu'on appelle un modèle de récompense,
qui va servir à aider le modèle de langage
à s’orienter vers des réponses qui ressemblent
à celles qu’attendent ou que préfèrent
les humains. Du moins les humains qui ont
fait les évaluations dans cette phase d’apprentissage
par renforcement.]
Cette phase est d'ailleurs aussi une façon
à ce stade de s'assurer que le modèle ne
sort pas de réponses qui pourraient être
jugées illégales, dangereuses, haineuses
ou tout simplement inappropriées pour l'usage
auquel il est destiné.
[RESUME Si on combine donc l'ensemble des
ingrédients qu’on a mentionné : fine-tuning,
apprentissage par renforcement avec feedback
humain, et preprompt, on comprend qu’il
est possible de spécialiser un modèle de
fondation.
Et d’en faire ainsi un chatbot comme ChatGPT,
qui soit plus pertinent, utile et plus respectueux
que GPT, qui avait simplement ingurgité tous
les textes d’internet.]
Alors à l'issue de tout ça : qu'est-ce qu'il
faut penser de ChatGPT ? Sur des questions
ayant une réponse simple et déjà bien documentée,
il fonctionne très bien. Mais en soi ça
n'apporte pas grand chose de plus que Wikipédia
ou une recherche Google.
Ce que l'on sait des modèles de machine
learning, c'est qu'il sont souvent assez bons
pour interpoler, c'est-à-dire bien traiter
une situation nouvelle, mais qui soit suffisamment
proche d'un ensemble de cas qu'ils ont pu
voir dans leur entrainement.
Et on peut souvent le vérifier ici : le modèle
peut produire des réponses intéressantes
et même inventives à des questions originales
ou pas forcément toujours bien formulées.
On décrit parfois l'intelligence ou la créativité
comme la facilité à relier des choses qui
n’ont pas forcément de lien apparent ou
évident. Et de ce point de vue là, c’est
intéressant de voir que ChatGPT montre des
signes indéniables de certaines de ces capacités.
On pourrait passer des heures à passer en
revue ce que ChatGPT fait bien, et ce sur
quoi il échoue lamentablement. Mais d'une
part vous en avez certainement déjà vu passer
plein d'exemples, d'autre part, ça bouge
tellement vite que tout ce que je pourrai
raconter sera peut-être caduc dans quelques
semaines.
Un point sur lequel j’ai envie quand même
commenter, et sur lequel ChatGPT est particulièrement
mauvais, c'est le fait de citer des sources.
Si on le fait parler d'un phénomène scientifique,
et qu'on lui demande les références des
publications d'où il tire ses conclusions,
on obtient la plupart du temps des articles
complètement inventés qui n'existent absolument
pas.
Ca peut paraitre assez embêtant, mais à
nouveau si on réfléchit à comment fonctionne
le modèle, on l'explique assez bien. GPT
ne raisonne pas, il ne cherche pas sur Internet,
il n'a pas de mémoire explicite : il se contente
de générer des textes plausibles dont les
mots collent bien ensemble.
Et quand on regarde le format des citations
d'articles scientifiques, franchement tout
se ressemble. Et donc n'importe quel séquence
de mots qui respecte vaguement le format standard,
ça passera à ses yeux comme une complétion
tout à fait crédible pour faire office de
référence scientifique.
D'autant que bien souvent dans un article
scientifique, les références sont groupées
en un gros paquet à la fin, et en lisant
uniquement ces sections, on a bien du mal
à deviner le contexte de chacune de ces citations.
Et pour ChatGPT, c'est un peu pareil, une
référence random avec à peu près les bons
auteurs et le nom d'un journal qui existe
vraiment, il invente un volume et un numéro
de page, et ce sera jugé comme parfaitement
raisonnable étant donné son mode de fonctionnement.
Ce problème spécifique des sources semble
assez difficile à résoudre en se basant
uniquement sur le principe d'un modèle de
langage. Mais on peut imaginer qu'en couplant
ces modèles a des mécanismes de recherche
sur Internet ou dans des bases de données,
cette question des sources inventées finira
par être résolue.
Merci d’avoir suivi cette vidéo, comme
toujours abonnez-vous, rejoignez aussi le
Discord de science étonnante, le lien est
en description, c’est le meilleur moyen
d’avoir des nouvelles qui ne soient pas
filtrées par l’algo Youtube, et on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo. A bientôt.
POSE MINIATURE